die Zahlen gehen nach oben und die
Zustimmung zu AFD geht nach der Witz ist
jetzt wieder
also diese Typen kommen bei uns nie an
die Macht in Deutschland aber man stelle
sich vor Sie würden sagen sie wird sie
sich sicher ja da bin ich mir sicher
Deutschland ist doppelt geimpft wir
hatten eine braune Diktatur eine rote
und eine weitere wollen wir nicht also
wir bleiben bei unserer gut das relativ
gut funktionierenden
liberalen Demokratie und wir sind nicht
Weimar dieses Land hat eine Demokratie
und genügend Demokraten weil immer hat
er eine Demokratie aber nicht genügend
genug Demokraten also wir schaffen das
die die mit diesem sie sind sich da ganz
sicher total absolut weil die haben zu
wenig anzubieten ja die haben ein
Programm für die Unzufriedenen für die
Heimatlosen für die die mit der Moderne
Fremden und das ist auch normal ich
fremde manchmal auch mit der Moderne ja
also das ist nicht gleich schlimm
[Musik]